[Music]
[Music]
Kingdom Hearts 3 is a game preoccupied
with fanservice and struggled to stay
coherent under the weight of its own
convoluted law but it's also everything
fans love about the series a thrilling
action RPG that celebrates Disney and
Pixar all the while ensuring themes of
friendship heroism and pure hearted
goodness shine bright at times those
themes can be difficult to discern
particularly when the game is intent on
telling the grander story of Kingdom
Hearts as opposed to the smaller tale
centered around Disney's iconic
characters or Sora's innocent idealism
given that it's the concluding chapter
in a massive story arc it can't be
followed for having this fixation but
the execution is frustrating nonetheless
Kingdom Hearts 3 is bogged down in the
finer details of its law so much so that
for all but the most clued in fans it
can be difficult to get a sense of what
our 3 main heroes are actually trying to
accomplish as broadus the story of
Kingdom Hearts 3 involves Sora Donald
and Goofy preparing for an upcoming war
against the forces of darkness by
gathering the guardians of light
this is oversimplification to its most
extreme but to delve into the finer
details would require lengthy
explanations of numerous confounding
concepts and characters is undoubtedly
messy but for fans who have committed to
playing all the games and been studious
enough to join the dots along the way it
makes sense for those that aren't as
well versed in Kingdom Hearts the
essentials of the story aren't laid out
nearly as clear as they need to be the
writing largely makes proceedings even
harder to follow the villains in
particular many of which are members of
organization 13 spout inane lines that
are purposefully vague presumably this
was to build mystery by only serves to
muddy motivations and further obscure
the crux of the story otherwise they're
delivering cheesy dialogue that feels
are ordered with the sincere melodrama
happening around them this is a shame
because at its core Kingdom Hearts free
is a heartfelt tale of enduring
friendship and the narrative is that is
strongest when it narrows its focus to
just this Sora Donald and Goofy are an
endearing trio they adventures through
the Disney and Pixar worlds as well as
the interactions they have with the
characters within them are a reminder
that beneath the torturous law are
smaller stories that resonate
by keeping the bigger Keyblade war in
the periphery and having minimal
involvement from all those involved with
it these stories are clearer and more
concise the underlying themes of Kingdom
Hearts harmonize with those of Disney's
own property so well that each new world
that saw her journeys to delivers an
impactful moment of storytelling
admittedly some of the stories retread
old grounds from the movies but whether
it's tangled pirates of the carribean
Winnie the Pooh Monsters Inc or Hercules
experiencing them again through the lens
of Kingdom Hearts 3 still packs an
emotional punch it's hard not to get
swept up in the exaggerated displays of
heroics or earnest reminders that your
friends exist in your heart one of the
strengths of Kingdom Hearts 3 is the
care and attention it pays to bringing
Disney's worlds to life which in turn
makes being in them all the more
exciting you get to wander around andis
bedroom as a diminutive toy version of
Sora scaling his walls and jumping on
his toys before making a trip to the
mall venture into the Pirates of the
Caribbean world and the game adopts a
striking realistic visual style and
gives you command of your own ship with
Jack Sparrow at your side San fransokyo
makes great use of verticality and
Sora's ability to effortlessly run up
buildings and glide between rooftops
while Monstropolis has you working with
Sully and Mike to stop Randal seizing
control of monsters ink and all the
while boo adorably Potter's around next
to you many of the walls offer extra
gameplay activities to engage with after
the story within them is wrapped up toy
box puts you in a mech and toss you with
destroying enemies in chasing high
scores Twilight town has a cooking
minigame which involves collecting
ingredients and bringing them to
ratatouille is Remy to make meals off
Pirates of the Caribbean lets you sail
the open sea or defend Port Royale in a
wave based minigame the amount of
gameplay in Kingdom Hearts 3 is
impressive and although the extras may
be short-term distractions for those who
want to spend more time in their
favorite worlds they're a fun reason to
make the return trip no awards maintain
that high bar as some feel either empty
or lacking in what they offer arendelle
snow-covered terrain for example feels
quite bland and the main mission
involves climbing a mountain more per
times portrayal is an entire location
used primarily for an item hunt toy
boxes Maul is devoid of life beyond the
toys and enemies
it would have been nice to have people
around to make it feel more alive
instead of like an after-hours shopping
center the same can be said of San
fransokyo which on ground level feels
eerily deserted for a metropolis the
bulk of Kingdom Hearts fries gameplay
however is in the sword-swinging magic
conjuring combat which feels fast
frenetic and spectacular in its
cinematic flourishes its most striking
feature is its fluidity Sora moves
between enemies quickly delivering a
barrage of attacks seamlessly
transitioning into casting spells
there's a pleasing sense of forward
momentum to all the bowels as you zip
around dispatching enemies in quick
succession
there are numerous layers on top of the
basic combat mechanics which while not
adding a great deal of depth or
strategic considerations make for more
exciting skirmishes keyblades now come
in a variety of flavors and have form
changes which transform them into more
over-the-top versions where more
powerful attacks and abilities become
available magic works similarly with
repeated use of a spell eventually
making a grand magic version available
and no additional mana cost throughout
Donald and Goofy will call to Sora for a
team-up attack these are characters that
have fought many battles side by side so
having these back and forth and
combination attacks are a nice
representation of the camaraderie
between them and their growth across the
series feeding into the Disney milieu
further our attractions such as tea cups
water offs bumper cars and a roller
coaster that can be summoned to dish out
damage each one controls differently
either through timed button presses
using the analog stick to guide their
path or becoming a first-person shooter
to pinpoint specific enemies they all
inject a different style of combat
gameplay into the action at regular
intervals
other Disney characters such as Simba
stitch and Ariel can be called into
bowel functioning similarly to Final
Fantasy summons to unleash devastating
special attacks the inclusion is
welcomed in lieu of giving them their
own worlds as some had in past games
beyond that this flow motion which
builds a sense of speed by encouraging
you to dash into objects in the
environment to swing around or at walls
to parkour along it can be tricky to get
a handle of but once you're able to work
these moves into the flow of combat you
build a sense of powers over the
battlefield watching the battles unfold
you'd be forgiven for thinking that the
combat is a complicated dance of fingers
across buttons but Kingdom Hearts 3 is
simple to play which works in its favor
it prioritizes spectacle above all else
and delivers tremendously that's not to
say it's completely devoid of strategic
considerations but you'll need to play
on the harder proud difficulty if you
want the game to challenge you otherwise
barring a few endgame bosses the enemies
are pushovers another feature that makes
this return from Kingdom Hearts of old
is the gummi ship while gummi ship
segments in the past were on Rails this
time you have full freedom to fly
wherever you please space is littered
with treasures to find but you'll often
have to battle enemies to acquire them
the shooting in the gummi ship segments
while serviceable isn't satisfying the
combination of lackluster visual and
auditory feedback makes it hard to tell
whether you're actually doing any damage
and for the most part I found myself
absent mindedly holding the fire button
and waiting for things to explode
as the game reaches its conclusion the
ballot is heavily in favor of non-disney
worlds with a main story of Kingdom
Hearts can play out and resolve itself
many of the environments this happens in
or striking from pristine white cities
to strange modular arenas that can be
turned upside down at the whim of an
enemy but in these locales the game
trades the heart and whimsy of the walls
up until that point for heavy-handed
storytelling that inevitably communism
battles there are cheap and spammy to
play the payoff meanwhile isn't entirely
worth it as Kingdom Hearts 3 wraps up
its story in an incredibly unfulfilled
way but the story of Keyblade Wars
time-traveling villains body hopping
also-rans and world ending darkness
isn't what I'll remember about Kingdom
Hearts 3 all the series as a whole what
sticks with me is the exciting battle
against an element or tie-in with
Hercules taking Rapunzel out into the
unfamiliar wide world for the first time
snapping selfies with Winnie the Pooh
and going toe-to-toe with Davy Jones in
2002 as Sora
I left destiny islands to travel across
the universe and make new friends in
2019 I brought all one's home and I had
so much fun doing it
just keep at it and I know you'll be
stronger than ever yeah I might even end
up stronger than you are
[Music]
[Music]
you